bonjour et bienvenue pour suivre sur des
modèles tv cette finale du championnat
du monde féminin 2015 donc finale qui
oppose l'ukrainienne maria musi tchouk à
la russe natalya pogo nina marjanovic
mène aux points on est sur la quatrième
partie et en cas de match nul donc ou
deux victoires et bien maria musi tulle
sera sacrée championne du monde la russe
l'intérêt pour une île à doit absolument
l'emporter avec les noirs tâche
extrêmement difficile mais on l'a vu en
huitièmes de finale
en quarts de finale en demi finale à
chaque fois la russe natalia kuzyutina
revient dans le match est fini par
l'emporter donc elle est extrêmement
dangereuse et d'autant qu'elle est aussi
revenu dans le dans les matchs face à
des joueuses avec les pièces noires donc
elle est capable
y compris donc de gagner avec les noirs
donc c'est parti pour l'ukrainienne avec
eux quatre titre mondial en jeu e5
symétrique donc cavalier trois caves les
c6 et qu'avait laissé trois ça c'est une
surprise le couple qui avait laissé
trois un coup inattendu sans doute la
russe s'attendait plus à fourbe et 5
qu'on a déjà vu qui est qu'ils rentrent
soit dans une espagnole soit dans une
berlinoise y ont ajouté à lille 6 mais
on l'a vu mariam aux heat shock a très
très bien joué avec ifo bessaih
d'ailleurs puisqu'il l'avait emporté
avec les blancs et bien la russe peut
être aller prévu quelque chose peut-être
rentrer dans une robe plus tendues et
elle évite avec ce coup là elle évite la
préparation russe c'est un coup
psychologique fort sans doute une
préparation et donc ces partis cavaliers
m6 dès 4 ans et centrale puis on prend
la vallée prend fous ces cinq coups
extrêmement actif
fo 3 est maintenant sous les 4 alors ça
c'est étonnant fou c'est celle d'abord
qui permet aux blancs de sortir le fouet
3 est maintenant fou b4 ça c'est un coup
surprenant pourquoi pas full méca tout
de suite à ce cas là c'est une subtilité
on va pas rentrer dans le description
ici c'est extrêmement subtile mais
pourquoi pas attention les noirs menace
cavale et prend 1,4 puisque le cas les
6,3 maintenant ils cloués droit ici
étant derrière donc fou détroit protège
le pion à quatre c'est logique et
maintenant cavalier 5 petit rock petit
rock cavaliers des cinq les blancs ne
laisse pas les noirs choisir de doubler
les pions il aurait pu le faire me
donner la paire de fous ils ont donc
patienter et noir et maintenant que le
cas il n'est plus cloud et les bleus en
profitent pour se caler des cinq évitant
toute surprise à base d'oeuf ou prendre
cavalli c3 donc ici proposent soit un
échange avec 6 soit éventuellement le
clouage par fou j'ai cinq clous
lecavalier psy c'est que font les noirs
si l'on revienne avec le fouet cette je
peux prendre la paire de fou par cas va
les prendre 7 avec une position tout à
fait intéressante donc les normes us pas
faire pire cavaliers prendre pions prend
ici et après tours 8
fous eux deux notant que la structure
ici des pions ici quatre contre quatre
et trois contre trois ici la structure
des pions et symétriques voilà il n'y a
pas de il n'y a pas de distorsion
donc c'est des positions qui ont
tendance à être annuler hantz qui est
bon pour les pour les blancs un peu
moins bon pour les noirs étant donné
l'objectif du match fou et fuite
le fou rentrer à la maison dam des deux
les blancs n'ont aucun problème pour
l'instant dès 6 h 3 faut rappeler que
c'est les noirs qui peuvent essayer de
l'emporter extrêmement difficile à 6 se
presse pas tours a eu un
on continue son développement à six f4
alors à 6,1 dans l'optique de jouer
peut-être bessin mais aussi d'enlever
des
les possibilités de cavalli bessem si on
veut notamment par exemple sortir la
dame faut pas permettre aux blancs
d'embêter le pion c c est donc là si ce
double intérêt à la fois empêché la
libye est elle à envisager pourquoi pas
un des cinq ultérieure mais là donc f4
les blancs prennent la décision d'agir
sur le centre on va sortir ce cas valais
central
accablé 17 alors ça c'est kelly 17 c'est
pour replacer le cavalier alors soit en
c5 éventuellement soit en et 6 et
permettre ce fou s'est vite de se
libérer on va voir comment ce qu'on va
choisir aller ce que choisiront les
noirs ou s3 alors ses classiques de ce
type de position
à noter que le foin f3 contrôle bien la
case de 4 en prévision d'un futur
qu'avait laissé 5 ou d'un futur club et
m6 qui vise la case 4 pour le cavalier
soutenu par la tour le fou ici contrôler
la case une première fois on peut
envisager donc de faire un échange
éventuellement qu'avait laissé scène
voilà donc les noirs choisi ce qu'a
laissé scène alors 112 on n'a pas peur
d'un coup ici comme comme b4 qui bon qui
est tentant mais sûr parce qu'on attaque
le cavalier qui est obligé de rejouer
mais simplement les noirs jour et
lecavalier en le 4 avec une bonne
position lequel il attaque la dame on
voit la dame si la dame joue on peut
encore embêter les blancs par cavalli g3
puis envisager de cavalière 5 proposé un
échange et le fou c'est 8 sort et puis
ce pion des quatre avancée peut s'avérer
une faiblesse parce que les noirs vont
pouvoir jouer à 5
et si on pousse encore plus le pion il
peut plus on les avances les pions
pluies risquent d'être faibles il faut
jamais oublier ça et puis en cas de
prise et vit dans la tour la torah 8 va
se régaler sur la colonne a donc on
pousse les blancs à avancer leurs pions
bon donc qu'à laisser 5 il faut toujours
y réfléchir à deux fois comme ça avant
d'attaquer
m6 est bien sûr envie déjà plaint donc
là d'ailleurs
foued 2,6 alors qu'abby ses singles et
blanches ou f2 et blanc est vite
d'affaiblir et 2 en juin font f2
simplement bel atour contre leucate donc
on peut pas jouer avec les noirs
cavaliers aux quatre peut-être là
maintenant mais menace b4 et est une
vraie menace c'est possible tout reprend
tout reprendre et simplement fou 17
donc on n'a pas peur de b4 puisque sur
b4 on mettra le cavalier ans à 4 protégé
par le fou et ce cavalier contrôle des
cases dans le camp blanc en plus le cas
les enquêtes empêche toute poussée
ultérieure à 4 du pion voilà c'est le
type de position qu'on aime bien jouer
avec les noirs comme ça sur b4 comme ça
de venir sur les cases blanches
puisqu'on joue les pions socas noir donc
les blancs ne font pas cette erreur
simplement le centre est verrouillé les
noirs n'ont pas de possibilité vraiment
d'embêter les blancs au centre on tient
la colonne eu pour l'instant avec la
tour on a un beau cavalier en d4
on peut envisager voilà j'ai cas de
poussée du côté droit pourquoi pas
fawcett roi g2 carrément on amène le roi
est bien un peu plus vers le centre
proche de ses pions le pion le roi peut
être une pièce active aussi bien sûr
dans ce type de position où ils ne
risquent pas grand chose et la fouace 4
intéressant on veut échanger le fou et
de on veut affaiblir un peu la position
du roi blanc fou prend dans prend
regardez comme les blancs n'ont pas peur
puisqu'ils ont prévu simplement dame f2
voilà propose un échange de dames les
blancs se contentent bien sûr du nul qui
leur donne le titre mondial
mais bien sûr les noirs refuse ta meuf
six attaques que kiev 4 attention et la
tz3 g3 extrêmement surprenants
extrêmement surprenant puisque les noirs
peuvent jouer g5 qui affaiblira la case
f4 ici c'est tout à fait envisageable
ça viendra sans doute un peu plus tard
dans la partie
les blancs doivent défendre de la dame
bon à noter quand même que les noirs
malheureusement non plus le fou de cases
noires donc ce qui fait que même en
affaiblissant les cases noires c'est
moins dangereux que s'il est fou était
encore là
foot classement mission dont croit g3
ici les noirs se presse pas il joue à 5
à 5
on commence à mettre les pions sur cases
noires ils le sont déjà beaucoup pour
être de la couleur opposée de celle du
fou voilà on veut attaquer puisqu'on
veut essayer de gagner la partie faux
oubliez donc faut contrôler un maximum
de cases donc les pions souvent
s'occuper des cases noires pendant que
le fou lui s'occupe des cases blanches
dam des deux voilà on re centrale
recentre la dame notamment pour protéger
le pion f4 en prévision d'un futur gsm
et gsm quand même voilà on affaiblit les
cases m'en fous j'ai deux fous g2
simplement permet d'envisager pourquoi
pas des tours et fin pour protéger plus
et b5 et noir prennent de l'espace
allèles downey le fou 17 protège bien
mais 5 on peut envisager b4 et contrôler
des cases noires d'un gant blanc mais
trois dames g6 mg6 ça secoue est
difficile à expliquer alors c'est pas
évident parce qu'il faut garder des
pièces pour le noir parce qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'il faut essayer de gagner
donc les noirs font tout pour essayer de
gagner
on peut jouer b4 aussi ici pour prendre
les cases noires c'est ça pouvait être
intéressant et bond alghisi c'est un
coup difficile à comprendre puisque on
va sur casse blanche
on aime bien plus tôt avant la dame sur
la couleur opposée du fou mais les noirs
à ce qu'ils sont pas déjà au maximum de
leurs possibilités difficile à juger
à 3 à 3 regarder les blancs voient là et
c'est d'éviter quand même que les noirs
prennent toutes les cases à trois on
empêche b4 déjà la dame contrôle aussi
attention quand même parce qu'à tout
moment les noirs peuvent prendre en f4
des idées d'alger si ça pourrait de
aussi d'envisager dh 5 et en cas de
prison prend 1,4 avec un double échec et
le roi est obligé d'aller s'aventurer ce
qui est pas une bonne nouvelle alors
puis on prend un f4 échec dans prend la
dame bien sûr adam bien entendu vise ces
deux mais le cas les décades veille il
n'y a pas de problème tout est tenu de
la part des blancs la position des
blancs est toujours extrêmement solide
ils sont même davantage puisque c'est
eux qui tiennent le centre c'est
officiel la colonie et b4 enfin apprend
apprend alors à noter que non seulement
on contrôle les cases noires ici on se
lance pas très très embêtant mais
surtout on a libéré la colonna pour la
tour qui peut envisager pourquoi pas
devenir en a deux même si ce cavalier
des quatre suffi à contenir ces menaces
à noter qu'au niveau structurel ses deux
pions maintenant sont isolés comparé à
ces deux qui sont liées qui
désavantagent noir de ce côté-là
d'amédée 2 les blancs simplement
consolidé 10 au noir b à toi qu'est ce
que tu vas faire maintenant attention je
menace quand même le pion des quatre
hellsten qu ils en ont maintenant sur
d'un premier 4 ch prend et sur h prend
mais sur dame prend puisque le fou
protège et le roi blanc est totalement
dénudée c'est dangereux donc fais trois
ans revient f3 avec le fou on consolide
la position mais là on sent que les
derniers coups blanc était comme
peut-être un peu un peu faible demande
et de h5 les noirs déjà ont éliminé ses
pions un peu doublé puisque à tout
moment ils peuvent cependant g4 avec une
position d' attaque intéressante
puis on prend plus on prend évidemment
puisque sur sur fou prend ce serait une
faute grave puisque f5 le full cloud et
puisque la dame ici est en vis-à-vis du
roi donc il faut prendre du plomb et sur
f5 bon simplement consolidera la case g4
et tout de suite pourquoi pas touré
fuite ici
bon elle s'inquiétait envisage aussi un
tout de suite f5 menace quand même puis
on prend g4 mais on dénie d'un le roi le
roi noir et bon g4 on peut laisser les
noirs projet kde simplement on enlèvera
le fou probablement et c'est peut-être
pas très très grave
ou peut-être on joue dame f4 aussi bon
retour et fuite est intéressant puisque
sur f5 maintenant tu comprends mais la
tour vise ici visera la colonne f et les
noirs ici voilà de créer des contre
menace mais au fur et à mesure des
échanges la position vire en faveur des
blancs qui cherche uniquement à faire
nul évidemment super viennent ils vont
prendre la victoire mais ça c'est pas la
peine ils ont besoin que du fer nu leur
attention qu a laissé six menace échec
et fourchettes royal donc attention
alors on pourrait se prémunir en mai
dans ce cas là le cavalier viendrait
quand même en 7 et probablement pour
viser plus tard la case f5 avec une
magnifique cadeau f5 on jouerait
probablement sans doute d'un f4 ou de
choses comme ça où on pourrait aussi
jouer tourache un essai et blanc qui
pourrait attaquer donc attention on
comprend le cavalier et puis on prend à
la position est intéressante ou jouer le
guen du côté noir parce que on a
cavaliers contrefous donc c'est
asymétrique tout ce qui va dans le sens
de la symétrie et mieux pour faire mieux
pour vous pour essayer de gagner équipe
usée le couple le fameux couple dame
cavalier est extrêmement puissant en
attaque
voilà donc c'est un facteur qui peut
faire espérer les noirs ainsi positionné
le mans il n'y a rien de spécial le roi
blanc quand même peu faible et c'est
vrai qu'il est un peu dans les courants
d'air
mais le roi noir aussi ce qui fait que
ça peut se retourner assez vite
alors on a plus de pions devant lui donc
la tour ici si elle arrivait à s'activer
pourrait aussi créer des contre menace
il faut donc être extrêmement prudent
dans son attaque car il y aussi ce très
intéressant
on vise la casse g5 avec un câble très
actif qui pourra tout moment s'échanger
contre le cavalier contre le fu pardon
et la dame noire et le cavaliere forme
magnifique duo d'attaqué il faut faire
un faut être très prudent
d'un prend les blancs prennent b4 ses
responsables et les noirs pouvant
prendre bien sûr ici en contrepartie le
pion ces deux là position est
extrêmement tendue dams et 4 propose un
échange des dames qui avant qui
avantagerait 40 j'aurais bien sûr les
blancs sur d'impromptus on prend là nul
n'est plus très très loin le fou en
finale étant légèrement supérieur aux
cavaliers probablement surtout quand il
ya des plans des deux côtés ici puis ont
baissé contre pions g4 et blanc devrait
arriver à faire une nulle assez
facilement dame b2 tentant pour les
blancs maintenant de faire un tour
prendre si ce qui est possible pour
prendre 6 puis on prend d'emprunt avec
échec et ça pourrait ça pourrait suffire
pour faire une nulle on peut regarder
cette cette variante ici tout reprend
simplement on est obligé de reprendre
avec les nord d'emprunt échec et que
font les noirci et noir jouent tous
rêvent cette probablement sous des
scènes suffi puisque si les enfants
d'échecs avec la lame simplement je
bouge avec le roi est là nul me suffit
et si les noirs arrête de faire des
échecs après dame est fou je mets change
contre la torre vii et j'aime ton plus
au final donc une position avantageuse
voire même gagnante puisque je vais
pousser pions b et je veux menacerait
ses 7 puis on prend ces sept dames et si
le roi noir vient empêcher ce pion
simplement l'autre pions va à dame donc
ici sur tours fc est fou des cinq suffit
pour la nulle largement on croit g7 est
quasiment forcé ici est simplement je
peux sans doute ici faire dame échec et
il n'y a pas de solution pour les noirs
pour empêcher la nulle comment faire si
je viens à angers 6
je vais me prendre fou et cinq échecs
suivi du mat puisque sur roanne 6 je
vais faire damage cet échec
roger cinq dames g6 échec et mat donc
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
si je viens en h6 je perds la tour donc
ici il reste que le tour en fait f7
c'est le seul coup et l'a simplement
d'alger cinq échecs et que font les
noirs il semblerait que ce soit nul si
je viens sur la colonne h je vais me
prendre un à mach 5 échecs et si je vais
à la fuite d'un mesdames des huit échecs
dames j'ai cinq échecs
voilà donc la lah nul semble déjà être
possible pour les blancs après dame b 2
tours 3 6 semble forcer la nulle et les
blancs ne le voient pas très
certainement puisqu'il joue food et 5
alors ces sportifs aussi on pourrait se
dire mais ça laisse souvent les
possibilités câble et j'ai cinq
cavaliers bien au g5 bonnecaze sur 4
noir très difficile pour les blancs de
l'attaqué puis qu'ils ont foot place
blanche est un des maîtres quatre
attaques lecavalier tmg cette voie là je
protège et j'ai toujours des chances de
jeu le cavalier attention peut s'avérer
dangereux je contrôle des cases proche
du roi blanc il peut se passer encore
des choses les blancs viennent de rater
une combinaison qui leur donnait le
titre probablement tours 7
hélas les noirs optimisent leurs
placements au regard des très jolies
tout 1,8
tours à 8,7 et très bien défendu on
apprit simplement pris du cavalier tout
est tenu et suffisamment de défenseurs
trois défenseurs pour trois attaquants
ça tient elle cède pas de problème tours
à huit qui chez mes pièces au quasiment
au maximum de leurs de leur efficacité
pas tout à fait mais après dan 3 de la
part des blancs un coup un tout petit
peu faiblard puisque j'enlève une pièce
à l'attack de f7 regarder il faut que je
continue à contrôler le cavalier damage
6 et là c'est tendu là c'est tendu parce
que les noirs ne sont plus qu'à un coup
d'activer leur tour regardez si cette
tour vient on à 2 attention il peut y
avoir des simplement menace de matin il
ya aussi une menace de déchets qu'en f3
qui plus est il pourrait y avoir des
menaces de découverte de type cavaliers
échec et la dame pour réattaquer quelque
chose bon ça marche pas on pourrait
prendre
mais il ya des menaces tactique là qui
commencent à s'accumuler
on est en finale de championnat du monde
le titre est en jeu il reste peut-être
pas beaucoup de temps aux joueuses c'est
le 40e coup l'erreur est possible
attention attention attention
et là nous hitchock marié michaud va
jouer un très belle combinaison
il fallait voir elle aurait pu le faire
avant on a vu un
ce tour prend 1,6 semblait donner la
nulle déjà hélas elle va rentrer dans
une finale peut-être un tout petit peu
plus tendu mais quasiment aussi annulant
tu regardes est très jolie position là
nul suffit au blanc-four rappeler quand
même fou prend f7 faut prendre cette
sacrifice de fou mcl sacrifices les
noirs vont le prendre parce qu'il n'y a
pas trop le choix
si je viens sur cases noires par exemple
si je joue maintenant un coup comme le
roi et fuite quand même envisageable
simplement regarder le foot bien h5 et
c'est fini a plus de menace sur la
colonne h
et c'est les blancs qui vont finir la
tacc de façon victorieuse là le roi noir
est totalement aux fraises et simplement
ils vont cette fois même gagné la partie
donc fou prend 1,7 il faut prendre et
maintenant simplement les blancs échange
les dames
voilà et ab troupes et après pardon tout
reprend ses sept
c'est presque nul puisqu'il suffit de
maintenant que ce pion des six
disparaissent et c'est nul un tour et
cavaliers contre tours ça ne gagne pas
c'est assez facile à défendre bon faut
faire un peu attention mais c'est quand
même assez facile à défendre beaucoup
plus que touré fou contre tours où il ya
des positions gagnantes donc comme l'a
rappelé plusieurs fois donc tout
repenser cette très intéressant cette
combinaison et les finales regarder
alors les blancs comptent sur le fait
bien sûr heureusement que les blancs il
reste des pions blancs parce que si les
noirs avaient encore le pion des six ans
les pions blancs
là par contre ils ont gagné parce qu'ils
vont valoriser leurs points de plus on
le protège par quatrième set et ensuite
ils vont arriver à le mettre en route et
c'est lui qui va décider mais là les
blancs en plus son option c'est cette
proche de dames un pion b qui peut en
plus créer une diversion
on n'est pas loin de faire tourner cette
attaque le pion c'est cette menace pour
ces huit échecs suivi de ces huit dames
et c'est très difficile à paris donc là
les noirs d'abord commence par protéger
leur seul atout qui leur reste il faut
qu'ils gagnent noir donc il s'est
commencé par protéger le pion
développions des six seule chance pour
les noirs c'est de garder ce pion et là
regardez simplement b4 voilà mes cadres
et je menace b5 b6 mais cette tour c8 et
dames c'est long mais que font les noirs
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'elles
n'ont pas de possibilité de se défendre
de façon efficace par exemple six tours
b 8
et bien simplement je peux jouer
tours à 7 voire même tour c'est ton tour
set je me plus me faire attaquer du roi
des airs donc plutôt tour à 7
hélas il est noir prennent ici
simplement je fais d'abord échec que
pour les noirs base simplement roi g7
quasiment forcé et maintenance et s'être
terminées les blancs s'en sortent
tranquillement puisque on va faire dame
avec une position peut-être même
gagnante pour les blancs tout cas avec
l' avantage qualité il ya une qualité
net de plus avec pio contre pions et
peut-être les blancs peuvent même gagner
cette finale
donc voyez b 4 tours b 8 suffit pas à
envoyer parce qu'en fait on des villas
tour à l'idée de b4 c'est de lathauwer
s'occupe d'eux se plante pendant que je
vens le pion le pion c'est donc là les
noirs trouve une autre façon de faire
cavalier 5 pour ramener le cavalier
proche du jeu il faudrait aussi pouvoir
ramener le roi mais les blancs laisse
pas les noirs s'organiser b5 b6 bessette
tour ses huit des huit dames maintenant
tombé huit tours bessette a alors ça
c'est un coup extrêmement hauts
responsables tour bessette
qu'est ce qui se passe sur tout
reprendre et 7 quel art très intéressant
puisque après s'éprend 17 simplement
cavale et 17 et forcé pour éviter la
dame dit maintenant il faut vite pour
les blancs s'occuper du bion d66 les
noirs arrivent à s'organiser ça risque
d'être chaud le roi f4 arrive cette
année c'est assez simple en fait alors
je vais pas faire trois ou quatre parce
que je me prends cavaliers ces cinq
échecs cavale et prend bessette qui en
plus contrôler le pion des six je fais
plutôt je crois que trois là pour éviter
l'échec est sûr maintenant
roy 8 pour aller chercher le pion
bessette avec le roi simplement roi des
4es ce roi des 8
regardez c'est l'autre pion qui va jouer
aussi un rôle on peut jouer b6 aussi
pour empêcher ici regardez le roi noir
ne peut pas venir puisque sur cavalli
est sûre cavaliers proche d'ebay huit
dames et le roi est coupée à la b6 est
aussi tom un coup assez fort et
maintenant que font les noirs s'ils
enlèvent le roi je peux jouer alors sur
roy hausse est par exemple tiens on peut
on peut faire que ça son gros soit
cavaliers 8 mai le cavaly s'éloigne soit
3,7
on peut regarder calais 8 et simplement
maintenant j'ai celle qu est le roi et
le roi il va être obligé d'aller
s'occuper de ce pion ces mêmes c'est
sans doute perdu parce que je vais jouer
ensuite trois des cinq le pendant que le
roi va prendre ce pion je vais prendre
des 6 et je vais jouer on voit ses sets
3-6 wee b 8 dames et ensuite c'est le
dernier pion qui risque l'emporté donc
voyez même avec une pièce de moins on
peut l'emporter dans cette finale avec
les tous les pions que l'on a donc b4
cabrios nb5 c'est pas simple tour b 8
tours bessette la prise et ne marche pas
parce que le pion j'ai heureusement il
ya se plonger aussi pour les blancs bien
sûr se plonger oblige les noirs à en
tenir compte et on peut pas protéger à
la fois les dames et les loin donc on va
pouvoir prendre le pion des six est un
cavalier seul ne mate pas un don ici
tour c'est 8
j'ai un oeil sur le pion le pion c est
simplement maintenant j'amène le roi f4
au bon moment et je veux venir en d5
calais des trois échecs 4 qu'avait
laissé 5
regardez on laisse faire la fourchette
ici ça c'est intéressant trois des cinq
et la halle et noir tentent leur
dernière cartouche
parce que là la menace bien sûr c'est de
prendre enfin ce pion des six et là
c'est fini parce que les pions sont trop
trop proche de dames la tour ne peut
rien faire tout seul le roi est trop
éloignée ici car les prend 17 quand même
c'est prend hélas très joli coup
de pogo nina qui ne lâche rien elle
pourrait jouer ici un coup comme tourbe
et 8-k l'air intéressant mais simplement
je peux même prendre le pion de 2,6
tranquillement menace roi c7
donc il faut prendre ici est simplement
je croise et 6 où va la tourbe est sans
doute l a pas trop le choix il faut que
soit qu'elles prennent le pion mais dans
ce cas là c'est nul ou si je joue tour
b8 simplement des 6-17 maintenant on va
suivre suivi de race et 7 et les noirs
ne peuvent rien faire le roi noir est
beaucoup trop loin pour empêcher
regarder que roy et puis on compte
retour ça permet largement de compenser
si on est proche de dames commission que
le roi adverse évidemment soit loin ce
qui est le cas ici donc c'est prendre 17
malgré la tour 2 - les pions blancs sont
beaucoup trop menaçants mais tour des
huit est intéressant puisque maintenant
si évidemment sion joue buis qui a tout
reprend et seront rois prendre des six
tours prendre les 5 et 6 les noirs qui
gagne et si je viens en c6 et bien je
peux envisager de pousser le pion des
dons qui arrive en premier c'est pas
clair alors les blancs se pressent pas
regardé très précis b6 d'abord messi
d'abord pour dire aux noix bientôt de
jouer tu peux pas jouer des cinq tout de
suite moi j'avance commencé à avancer
leurs pions b parce que je sais que si
je fais une première dame bien tu va
l'apprendre et j'aurai besoin d'un pion
b qu'ils soient déjà avancé donc autant
l'annoncer tout de suite
étampes et de retarder autant que
possible son coude et 5 très intéressant
donc là les noirs donc un coup droit a
joué voilà mais non pour les blancs font
pas traîné roy c6 simplement et regardez
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe sur
des cinq simplement 3 c'est cette menace
de prendre la tour si des cats je prends
la tour des 3
je fais dames et il me manque encore
deux coupes on a vu pour les noirs donc
là là on un peu foutu il faut jouer roy
e set et là regardez maintenant sur b 8
dames tout reprend roi prend maintenant
des quatre des sept détroit
hu a sans doute en a 7 ou en c7
peu importe des deux voies la dame dame
leblanc de jouer c'est le camping en
plus de même encore essayé de jouer pour
le gain il n'y a aucune chance pour les
noirs de gagner ça voilà c'est ou bien
que je voulais donc on va jouer sans
doute d'un bep quatre échecs
et puis selon on va jouer aux joues les
noirs on va sans doute encore fait un
échec en escarra trou avec une position
bien entendu supérieure avec le pion de
plus voilà donc b6 très fort coup l'un
d'eux m'a rien dit ou qui sans doute là
sait déjà qu'elle va être champion du
monde pro gaudinat encore wife 7 dont on
croise et 6 c'est leur 3e set et
maintenant simplement trois c7 est la
bonne il apprend la nul avec échec 3 c6
simplement je reviens des 8 et la partie
nuls simplement les noirs empêche les
blancs de faire dame croit ses sept
tours 17
3 ces six tours des 8 et sans doute ici
répétition de coûts tout simplement ou
propositions nul peu importe parties
nulles et donc au bout des quatre
parties mariam aux it shoe gagne le
match
une victoire à zéro avec trois parties
nulles et sacré donc championne du monde
d'échecs bravo à l'ukrainienne maria
masycheva aussi très beau championnat de
pogo nina qu'on a pu suivre bien sûr
puisque on avait suivi le parcours de
marie sebag et qui a rencontré pogo nina
et ça s'est joué à très peu de choses
donc on peut avoir des regrets pour
marie sebag puis quand on vole parcours
de pogo nina elle aurait pu alors ait pu
sans doute arriver en finale et qui sait
ce qui se serait passé alors elle avait
donc le niveau pour arriver au bout mais
malheureusement c'était pas pour cette
fois peut être une prochaine fois
à noter que la championne du monde maria
musi tout jouera un match cette fois
pour le prochain titre de champion du
monde face à l'ifan goût où on peut
10 ou lifan parfois mais son prénom
c'est ifan donc il faudrait plutôt dire
les fans ou qui est bien a remporté le
grand prix qualificatif préalable à ce
championnat
elle jouait pas ce championnat par
élimination mais elle jouera le match
pour récupérer son titre puisque elle
est championne en titre sortant a noté
que l'iphone où elle fait partie des
trente ou quarante meilleurs joueurs du
monde toutes catégories et à une classe
d'écart par rapport à maria musique zouk
quel que soit son talent puisque le
classement elo est quand même bien
supérieur elle partira archi favorite
iphone ou face à donc c'est quand même
cette magnifique championne du monde à
maria amouzou qui a montré quand même
très bon niveau de jeu et le match
prochain risque d'être fort intéressant
entre les deux sexes enfin entre les
deux champions du monde entre la tenante
donc mariam ou zouk et la sortante ifan
où ça va être passionnant voilà donc
bravo à mariam ouzou pour ce titre qui
rentre dans la légende qui est je crois
la 15e champion du monde féminine de
l'histoire et je vous dis donc à bientôt
sur diagonale tv merci d'avoir suivi au
revoir